[Musique]
soit 100
moi cette fois
en france dans les grandes villes du
pays les fossoyeurs n'ont plus le choix
il faut faire de la place dans les
cimetières
quitte à exhumer les restes anciens
isabelle borne ministre du travail de
l'emploi et de l'insertion que nous
sommes heureux de retrouver en bonne
santé
merci monsieur le président quatre
nouveaux milliardaires français qui
entrent dans le classement forbes
il ya quarante deux milliardaires
français au total les quatre nouveaux
stéphane bancel pdg de moderna qui entre
directement la 23e place
la crise aura bien profité aux plus
riches si jeff bezos le patron d'amazon
est toujours numéro 1
les 20 premiers de ce classement ont vu
leur fortune augmenté de 62 % en un an
les gens voient bien que les médecins
sont pas d'accord qu'il ya toujours des
nouvelles qui sont difficiles que les
vaccins n'arrive pas comme on voudrait
que ya des variantes qui viennent
troubler la donne
on se rend bien compte que c'est très
difficile de prévoir et donc ont
finalement le président préserve les
équilibres je pense des caps étaient
donc ça nous on ne discute pas un secret
déjà été faite ni cap'ados réaffectation
de réorientation c'est forcément là ce
que la personne a choisi
sur les claustras zeneca et non
non mais
qui est plutôt dans
comme toujours avec leur accent anglais
adorent ce lien confirmé aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs par l' agence européenne et
l'isq de formation de caillot sanguin
après une vaccination avec deux
astrazeneca vont être ajoutés à la liste
des effets secondaires possibles axe
peut pas accès de peine et la balance
bénéfice-risque jugées positives
concernant le vaccin contre le coc vie
de 19 je me suis fixé à moi même
l'obligation de ne pas les raconter et
gilles ne s'est pas la teneur de
conversation que j'ai eue avec le
président de la république
non pas du tout que je ne ferais pas
confiance en aucune façon
mais parce que parce qu'il ya des choses
qu'un premier ministre ne nie pas alors
on va tout faire pour le maître du temps
c'est le virus alors qu'elle s'avance
aux côtés de charles michel le président
du conseil européen regarder ce qui se
passe
les deux hommes se dirige tranquillement
vers les deux sièges qu'ils en sont
réservés et on voit le petit geste du
madame von der leyen
et pour moi ya pas de siège maintenant
elle a été reléguée sur un canapé
donc c'est pas si c'est un rêve sur
l'art de gouverner en fait pour vous
dire la vérité il c'est le récit d'une
expérience à travers beaucoup d'exemples
des crises que nous avons vu que même
moi qui ne sait pas gouverner
j'ai pris des j'ai pris des notes oui
vous inquiétez pas il ya peut-être des
gens qui pensent que de nous pour arnaud
montebourg marie le pen va à gagner
l'élection présidentielle de 2022
pourquoi parce que dit-il emmanuel
macron et détester parce qu'il est trop
arrogant et qu'il n'est plus un rempart
du côté des proches des manuels macron
ce qu'ils ont pensé
or pas de grandes surprises vous allez
voir on tacle l'ancien ministre garder
le problème c'est que mon bora toujours
confondu la tactique et la stratégie
il fait de la tactique faire monter
marine le pen pour prouver qu emmanuel
macron ne doit pas être candidats sans
stratégie pour la gauche il y avait une
marge de manoeuvre
je prends pourquoi j'ai pris mon verre
d'eau du premier ministre avec avec tout
ce qui va avec une marge de manoeuvre
c'est à dire une capacité à prendre des
initiatives capacité à se tromper mais
vous savez quand vous prenez 10 15 20
décisions par jour
et bien il y en a un certain nombre sur
lesquels vous vous trompez et puis
gérard darmon au coeur des critiques
l'acteur est vilipendé pour avoir posté
une photo de lui
maquillé en noir pour les besoins d'un
rôle gérard darmon se défend et affirme
qu'un comédien peut tout jouer